listen i couldn't be more excited for
this series i have been waiting for this
a very long time um i'm so curious um i
love learning about the behind the
scenes of the making of things so for
star wars fans like me what do you think
would surprise people to learn about the
making of obi-wan you know people might
be able to guess this but it's the most
important to me
you know is that it takes
so many people to make it happen
hundreds of people to make this happen
even like on the ground every day and it
doesn't happen unless people show up
cheerful about their job and ready to do
the work and the people who hand off the
lightsaber the people who you know
switch the boards in the back it takes a
lot of people to make it happen
what was it like actually getting to
train to use a lightsaber and like i
mean there's not that many people that
can say that they've done this
it's wild
um and to say that i got to train and
get that experience staying next to
obi-wan because we went to jedi school
together and so being in there every day
it was really inspirational because he'd
be in there he'd be really good at it
you know because he'd been doing it
forever
um and i and i had some trouble at first
but you know if at first you don't
succeed try and try again and it worked
out obviously like the lightsaber hilt
is a really big deal did they hand you
one or did they say here's 10 which do
you think your character likes
well
the
the saber that is for riva is like
particularly for her it's special and it
was custom made to fit my hands
um
specifically you know as we were finding
what works best and um it really is a
moment when you get to hold it for the
first time and it's yours
um and fight with it it's it's serious
yeah
uh hypothetically did you try to borrow
one from set
hypothetically
once or twice
i would have seriously done everything i
could to but anyway that's just me um
it's obviously it's a six episode series
uh which episode is your favorite and
why without spoilers oh you know what
and i'm not even i'm not being weird
it's very hard to remember
series order
by episode
um
but i can say that there are a lot of
crazy crazy cool moments in this thing
um
so many tweetable things um but it's
it's gonna be a wild one uh which of
your friends and family were the worst
that asking you to tell them spoilers
probably
you know what people were really good
about it i think that the
the more surprising thing about my
friends and family is you know as we've
gotten deeper into press them going
i didn't know you were like really in
star wars it's like it seems like you're
really in it and i'm like
that's because i am because i am
actually
oh i got to stop there i honest to god
i'm so excited for this i'm so happy for
you i wish you nothing but the best
thank you so much i appreciate it